sixty thousand haitian nationals are
expected to descend upon texas this week
and demand entry into our country
if past is precedent many if not most
will succeed in entering the country
illegally but while we prepare for that
imminent flood of foreigners another
organized caravan is preparing to depart
with its leader describing themselves as
ready for war but americans are not
ready to fight that war because
americans are too preoccupied waging
what seems increasingly to be a cold
civil war at home a dilemma made all the
clearer by the fact that the leader of
the next illegal alien brigade is an
american himself i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from random who
says
let's go brandon very simple right to
the point i don't think it could
possibly be more clear
let's go
brandon
you know when i want to easily
understand things and i want to
help myself out
one place that i always look is
rockauto.com you probably have a lot of
free time right you got you got nothing
to do you got no pressing matters so i
hope you have a lot of free time if you
want to go get an auto part at the brick
and mortar auto parts store because
you're gonna have to drive there get out
of the car wait in line
get peppered with a thousand questions
tell the guy all these answers if you
got him about your car then he looks in
the back he doesn't have the parts
because i know the companies can't store
all of these different parts for all the
makes and models then they'll come out
and they'll say sorry we don't have it
we got to order it they go online
probably to rockauto.com then you gotta
wait a bunch of days and pay twice as
much so you can either do that or
just go straight to rockauto.com on your
phone on your computer it's very easy so
simple to navigate even i can do it
they've got all the parts that you're
gonna need for your car or for your
truck reliably low prices family-run
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck and
then write knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s in there how did you hear
about xbox so they know that we sent you
60 000 haitian migrants
entering this country
illegally there maybe they'll go through
some kind of processing they're not
going to actually come into this country
through the legal channels many of them
will be given a court date they'll never
show up to the court date they'll just
be released into the interior of the
country some of them will just sneak
across won't even be apprehended maybe
some of them will be turned back but if
past is president not very many and then
we've already got the next migrant
caravan coming up this one is being
organized by a group that for years has
flouted america's immigration laws and
committed a lot of crimes against the
united states this is a group called
people without borders or pueblo sin
fronteras
the leader of which is an american
citizen so this is what what the leader
of this particular caravan says he says
quote we're leaving in 20 days we prefer
to march with papers and this time with
papers or without papers we are ready
for war
if the national guard comes and it's
unclear if he's referring to the mexican
national guard or the united states
national guard and they are cowardly
enough to beat women and children does
that happen i don't haven't seen a lot
of that uh let them prepare because
god's hand is with us we are ready for
war
a few years ago when one of these
other immigration issues bubbled up
i had a debate with a friend of mine
because i referred to it as an invasion
i said we are being invaded by
foreign people and a friend of mine very
intelligent person
generally very conservative person he
said oh that's outrageous that's
hyperbolic it's not an invasion
this is people who maybe they're
escaping persecution maybe they maybe
they just want economic opportunity
frankly if you were in their position
you'd probably do the same thing michael
it's not right to call it an invasion
there's a distinction to be had
he told me between
you know the barbarians at the gates
and people who just want to come into
america and improve their lot in life
okay agree to disagree we said
this situation that we're looking at
this i think is inarguably an invasion
when you have the group of people saying
we are ready for war
we are going to come and commit acts of
war i think it's pretty clear that you
are dealing with people who are invading
your country
certainly the group organizing this
puego pueblo
that is a group that is waging war
against the united states
certainly the cartels that are ferrying
people across certainly they are waging
war against the united states
and what are we doing about it
nothing even when border patrol is
trying to stop it the politicians tie
their hands behind their backs
they say no you can't use horses you
can't actually enforce the law you've
just basically got to stand there and
take it
and our guys are being mocked
border patrol is being mocked by some of
the worst people on earth these drug
cartels at the southern border
there are right now this according to
bill malugan
is in magulan or maclugan i'm certainly
mispronouncing his name he's a very good
reporter he tweeted out quote it was
reported that in multiple
instances over the past several days
texas border patrol tells me suspected
cartel gunmen involved in human
smuggling have stood in and near the rio
grande and star county and taunted texas
national guard soldiers they were attack
vests and have ak-47s so we now have
some of the worst most degenerate
filthy dangerous criminals on earth the
cartels right down there at the southern
border
are wearing body armor and they are
waving ak-47s like they are osama bin
laden like they are soviet soldiers or
the other
militants who stole soviet weapons
at the border mocking what is supposed
to be the strongest country in the world
with our national guardsmen
standing there at the border and there's
nothing they can do what are they going
to do
the minute they fire a shot the minute
they in any way defend the country
the
political apparatus is going to punish
them
so now we are being made a mockery
in this situation
we should deploy the military
whether whether that's national guard
whether we're sending in the marines
the purpose of a military is to protect
the country and politicians of both
parties are very loose about deploying
the military when it involves
crusades overseas to send afghan women
to go study gender studies at the
university then that's the absolutely
appropriate use of american military
might to fly over to some god forsaken
backwater in the middle east so that we
can install madisonian democracy in some
sharia-run
wasteland that is the that's a good use
of the military that's a legitimate
constitutional just use but protecting
our southern border which is now
being which does not exist first of all
and
across which many many
very bad people drug cartels people
preparing for war are flooding into our
country
to say nothing of the alleged pandemic
that we're living through right even
even if they were the nicest people in
the world we're not supposed to leave
our homes but we're letting
just thousands and tens of thousands of
foreign nationals pour over the border
constantly
that's not then you're not allowed to
use the military is that right do i have
that right it's a joke it's a farce
that's a force and increasingly you are
seeing serious conservatives come out
and say send in the marines jd vance i
think said something to that effect with
regard to the immigration issue of
course
this is this is a good
uh litmus test
because
the squish conservatives the squish
republicans who have really dominated
over the past 20 or so years they're
going to look at the situation at the
border and say well you know actually i
was doing the gdp charts and it turns
out that the migration is actually
really good for big corporations and big
corporations are good for america ticks
up gdp so
right and so
forget about american wages forget about
american security forget about american
law all of that goes to the wayside
because big corporations think they can
squeeze illegal aliens for a little bit
more money and the democratic party
thinks they can squeeze them in their
descendants for votes so
nation be damned we've got to open up
the borders or you've got the
conservative candidates who say you know
whatever contributions foreigners might
make to our country we cannot have a
system where our laws are flouted all
the time so no we've got to say no
we've got to enforce the border
those are the conservatives
to follow
and it it's a popular issue by the way
most americans think that we need to
drastically reduce immigration not just
illegal immigration but legal
immigration too we just take in too many
people and it's causing problems it's
not even the migrants fault it's just
the fact of it you can't take in in this
country more people than have ever moved
largest migration in the history of
recorded time
in the past 60 years into the united
states and just expect there not to be
any cultural effects of that of course
there will be
okay
we take so many more people and than any
other country on earth and there's just
a limit to what you can do if you take
in every country then you don't have a
country anymore
this is a popular
issue but there are entrenched interests
that want to
that want to keep the situation as it is
to maintain the status quo but the polls
are very clear gallup just showed
that republicans have a huge advantage
over democrats on security and
prosperity issues so right now
a significant margins view the
republicans is better than the democrats
at protecting the nation from
international threats that's 54 to 39
percent
and
ensuring that the nation remains
prosperous that's 50 to 41
so what does this mean a lot of people
are saying well this bodes really well
for republicans in 2022. i agree it does
if it's a fair election
right if the democrats rigged the
election then it's not going to matter
the polls could be forget about 50 or 41
54 to 39 it could be 90 to 10 it won't
really matter
so how do we look at that i think what
is very important for us to do
is in 2022 go out and vote for the
candidates that we want we or write in
your mail on ballot or whatever yes i
know these systems are rife with fraud
yes i know that the democrats are
rigging these things intentionally to
give them an advantage but the trick
that the democrats have pulled here is
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy if
you have absolutely no faith in the
electoral system and you don't
participate and you stay home and you
don't go vote then the democrats can
just point to that and say no don't
worry republican votes were just
depressed so people were people weren't
going out there so that's why we won
whereas if we do go out if you make a
big show of voter enthusiasm on the
right we still lose then it's there's
far greater evidence that they rigged
the thing
but but right now if it's a fair
election in 2022 and the election were
held today
there is no question that republicans
would absolutely dominate and and a big
part of that is because joe biden is
extremely unpopular and you're seeing
this reflected not just in the
right-wing polls but even in decidedly
left-wing polls
joe biden's numbers are in free-fall
now a lot of this has to do with the
economy being in absolute turmoil when
you want to hedge your investments
against crazy economic term well what
would i recommend i would recommend you
check out acre gold you may have noticed
that the economy is going completely
insane these days and prices are going
way way up and income is not going way
way up and a lot of people are worried
about the direction of our economy well
one way to hedge your investments is
with physical gold now i know what
you're thinking michael i can't i can't
afford a physical gold or physical
precious metals you can you can actually
for as little as 30 a month no i can't
michael you're a liar before you call me
a liar check out what acre gold is doing
you subscribe to their gold bars
for 30 a month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your door they've got
a new hundred dollar a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar i
love it i have really enjoyed investing
in physical precious metals and in acre
gold right now you can go visit acre
gold dot com slash knowles can o w l e s
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweeter post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
thank you acre gold for supporting the
show i've got these new numbers here
from quinnipiac
quinnipiac is a college in connecticut
they put out a lot of polls
why am i focused on the quinnipiac poll
because the quinnipiac poll
skews
extraordinarily to the left
the quinnipiac poll and molly hemingway
pointed this out yesterday the
quinnipiac poll will regularly predict
huge democratic victories and they'll
end up being huge republican victories
the the quinnipiac poll
is not reliable to be right down the
middle it skews heavily to the left and
even
quinnipiac
is saying
that biden is is plummeting
so right now
on biden's response to
or on biden's handling of the economy 39
approved 55 percent disapprove really
bad news his job as commander-in-chief
37 approved 58
disapprove taxes 37 approved 54
disapprove foreign policy 34 approved 58
disapproved migration oh my gosh
immigration 25 percent approve so only
one in four americans approves of joe
biden's handling of immigration 67
percent two-thirds disapprove the
mexican border issue it's even more
skewed 23 percent approved not even one
in four
67 disapproved
even uncovered
kovid was always biden's saving grace
that's why he's focusing on the
lockdowns that's why he's trying to gin
up all this fear again that's why
especially after afghanistan collapsed
he just tried to make a hard pivot back
to kovid even on kovid
which had been his strongest number 48
approved
50
disapprove
really really bad stuff even even down
to personalities rates
does joe biden care about the average
american
only 49 say yes 48 say no to put that in
context back in april 58 thought that
biden cared about him the average
american 37 thought he did not now it's
basically evenly split
is joe biden honest 44 say yes 50
say no
that's compared to 51 saying yes he's
honest 42 saying no he's dishonest back
in april and his leadership skills 41
41 say he has good leadership skills 56
say no he does not that is compared to
52 to 44 back in april
and more than half of the country 55
percent of americans say that joe biden
is not competent in running the
government that's 55 say he's completely
incompetent versus 42 percent who say
he's competent
devastating if this is what quinnipiac
is saying
what are the actual numbers
you think you think it's hard for those
numbers to get even worse but certainly
certainly they are
well you hear it you heard it in the
comment today let's go brandon which is
a euphemism for people expressing their
displeasure with joe biden you heard it
when joe biden just went to visit
michigan joe biden just went to visit
michigan
occasionally he tries to get out of the
house it's good for him to get fresh air
it's good for him to get a little
exercise you know remember what day it
is so so joe biden goes to michigan and
as he's driving up in the presidential
motorcade
there are people chanting
f joe biden f joe biden also known as
let's go brandon there are signs that
say f joe biden
and joe biden gets to his campaign stop
he's standing in front of a caterpillar
piece of you know big big heavy
equipment
and he's good american manufacturing
good american farm jobs he's an
all-american guy and joe biden has the
audacity
to
claim that he is the most popular
president in american history one more
vote than anyone else
i took this agenda to the country
they said it was time to build an
economy that looks out from scranton
pennsylvania where i grew up as a kid
instead of looking down from wall street
an economy looks out from holland
michigan and towns like it all over
america that brings people from every
race background religion into the game
that's what
notwithstanding some of the signs i saw
come that's why 81 million americans
voted for me
the largest number of votes in american
history
a clear majority
were supporting
when they supported me
so joe biden
he's clearly irritated by the let's go
brandon stuff and by the signs because
he references the signs
right he says notwithstanding some of
those signs that i saw you know all the
ones people saying how much they hate my
guts uh i got the most votes of anyone
in american history i'm so popular i go
81 million and then what do you hear in
the crowd do you hear that all that
excitement you just hear this you're
like yeah
uh 80 uh they're like six people out in
the crowd
you actually when joe biden first got
there he walks in you know he wants to
make his rock star entrance by the way i
know it's easy to forget this guy is
supposed to be the president of the
united states right you want to walk out
you want to walk out to proud to be an
american with 50 000 people there just
like at the trump rallies yeah joe biden
woo the president
what happens he walks out here's his
response
hello michigan
it's good to be back
hello michigan
that is i think indicative
of something that we talk about a lot on
this show which is the the difference
between
the appearance of how things are and how
things really are the
huge gap the chasm between what our
ruling class
tells us the world is like and the the
situation on the ground is and what the
real situation on the ground is so what
the ruling class says is
joe biden got the most votes ever he got
70 gazillion votes
and more than no i think 700 000
gazillion votes and it was he's the most
popular president ever in american
history and yeah never mind that no one
showed up to his rallies and never mind
that in order for for him to win the
white house we had to change all of the
election rules and you know spend days
and weeks counting it and uh never mind
that people keep booing him everywhere
there's a crowd in the entire country at
sports games at concerts and everything
no he got a gazillion billion zillion
votes and he's super duper popular and
then there's the reality which is
anywhere this guy goes people boo him
and they heckle him and all of the
public opinion polls are saying that
he's deeply deeply unpopular even the
ones that are supposed to skew to his
side all say
no one likes him
nobody really believes
that joe biden is the most popular
president ever no one believes it even
the people who are claiming it to you do
not really believe it we're all just
lying to one another and to ourselves if
if we are reciting the left-wing
dominant narrative okay it's it's sad
but everyone seems to be comfortable
with with the fact that we're living in
lies stephanie grisham former uh aide to
the trump white house she was a press
secretary
we didn't see very much of her as press
secretary but now she's come out with a
tell-all book and she's turned on trump
and she's trying to suck up to the
liberal establishment and betray all of
her benefactors and she she wrote this
big tell-all and
and
she is running into a problem here
that a lot of these snakes run into
which is
she
worked for trump she benefited from
trump trump gave her her career and now
that trump can't help her anymore she
turns on him and tries to make a buck
but
the only reason that her account matters
at all is if she's giving an honest
depiction of what happened in the trump
white house
but if she is giving an honest depiction
then she's outing herself
as having previously been a liar
did do interviews on fox though yes
were you always truthful there
i probably wasn't i can't on i can't
think of a
of an example right now i probably
wasn't i mean and i regret that so much
i i think of one example when i put the
statement out about general kelly we
have that can we put that up so people
can see because i want i want you to i
want you to diagram yes this if we can
if we have that can we put up this was
2019 october of 2018. i can't remember
what kelly did but he pissed off the
president in some way he said something
mildly disparaging and then what
happened was the president forced you to
put out a statement and i'll paraphrase
here if you don't have it which
basically says i worked with john kelly
and he was totally unequipped to handle
the genius of our great president
he
trump dictated that to you yes i that's
i don't speak that way yeah that he
dictated that to me word for word he
dictated that i really i i'm i'm sorry i
regret it i shouldn't have sent out that
statement that official statement i as
the spokesman sent out and i shouldn't
have lied on tv i i'm acknowledging i
definitely lied on tv but believe me now
yeah i'm a liar
and my job was to be a paid liar i'm
telling you but now believe me why would
i believe you you're not a trustworthy
person you don't have integrity
you don't have integrity in that you're
willing to betray your benefactors the
moment you think that you can get any
sort of advantage so you have no loyalty
whatsoever but you're even admitting
that your job in your job you were lying
so the only role that we really know you
for
you were being dishonest so why are we
going to believe you now
i i certainly don't
that's i don't think these account this
is why i haven't really covered
stephanie grisham's stupid book she's
just trying to cash in and a lot of
people do this and it's really tawdry
and it's not nice but also there's just
nothing valuable in it because
either she was if she was lying then she
could be lying now and if her if her
word is not worth anything then who
really cares what she has to say i'm
going to focus more on
actual journalists who are uncovering
people sort of telling the truth and
what they think are moments of candor
like james o'keefe did over project
veritas he's got some great new stuff
coming out on pfizer and on the covid
vaccine first though
when you want candor when you want a
very serious conversation about what's
going on in our politics and the
conservative movement i would strongly
recommend you go check out the national
conservatism conference that is coming
up it's gonna be coming up at the end of
this month i'm extremely excited to be
speaking there they're going to be a ton
of great speakers uh joram hazoni is the
person sort of putting it on he's one of
the great political philosophers around
today
so go check it out i know there are some
people who want to go to the national
conservatism conference it's in orlando
but maybe they're a little tight on
funds well
yorum and the edmund burke foundation
have just announced
that there will be a michael knowles
fellowship for the national conservatism
conference you can be a null scholar
over at the national conservative
conference if you want to apply just
head on over to nationalconservatism.org
slash knowles kwles also this coming
tuesday october 12th we're making
backstage extra super duper exciting
instead of the usual daily wire studio
we will be live streaming our
conversation on stage at the famous
ryman auditorium right here in nashville
plus we're going to be making some
extremely exciting announcements which
you are not going to want to miss be
sure to tune in join me ben shapiro
candace owens jeremy bourne matt walsh
andrew clavin and our live audience for
backstage like never before tuesday's
live stream will begin 8 30 p.m eastern
7 30 p.m central head on over to
dailywire.com or the daily wire youtube
channel to catch the show and go tune in
to morningwire it's great show you can
subscribe apple spotify wherever you
listen leave a five star review we'll be
right back with a lot more
if you believe
that natural immunity is superior to
whatever antibodies you get from that
experimental drug
or the several experimental drugs of the
coveted vaccines well you're a wacky
kooky dangerous murdering terrible
conspiracy theorist based on fact check
say
not only is natural immunity inferior
but there's no such thing as natural
immunity some people have actually made
that claim well that narrative just got
a little bit punctured because james
o'keefe with his journalists over at
project veritas just sat down
on hidden camera with a number of
scientists from pfizer putting out
one of
probably the most prominent covid
vaccine
and caught a bunch of them admitting
that natural immunity is
not only a real thing but is superior
vastly superior to the coveted vaccine
when somebody is
naturally um immunes
like they got covered
they probably have better like not
better but more antibodies against the
virus
because
what the vaccine is is like i said that
protein so that's just on the outside
so it's just one antibody against one
specific part of the virus
when you actually get the virus you're
gonna start producing antibodies against
like multiple pieces of virus and
not only just like the outside portion
like the inside porcelain the actual
virus so your antibodies are probably
better at that point than the
vaccination so i'm well protected
like as much as the vaccine probably
more
how so like how much more you're
protected
most likely for longer
since there was a natural response we're
like bred and taught to be like
like
vaccine is safer than than actually
getting coke you cannot like talk about
this
in public
so there are this goes on and on for 10
minutes or something like that and maybe
longer these are three separate
scientists at pfizer all acknowledging
something that we all already knew but
we're not allowed to admit and if you do
say it then the fact checkers and the
social media and the authorities and
everything will will tell you that that
it's it's not true and you're a
conspiracy theorist but what we all know
is that natural immunity does exist and
even many scientists who are being shut
up but very prominent major serious
scientists are saying that natural
immunity
offers better protection against the
coronavirus than does the vaccine we
obviously we know this because the
vaccines had varying degrees of efficacy
and now just a couple months after
people have gotten the vaccines or less
we're being told that people need a
booster shot
so sure
now
this is already being suppressed
big tech doesn't want this getting out
the authorities don't want this getting
out very likely this show will be
censored in some way because we just
played the clip of pfizer scientists
coming out and saying
these sorts of things
we need to ask why why is that is it
because of the are the pfizer scientists
spreading misinformation well okay if
there's disagreement among the
scientists there isn't really by the way
all the actual scientists say there is
such a thing as natural immunity and it
is superior to
to a
vaccine
protection but but even if there were
some disagreement why are we only
favoring one kind of one group of
scientists over some other group of
scientists even within the same
companies even within the same
institutions it's because of political
calculations
right it's because
the vaccination
regime offers
a
a political power grab a political
advantage to the people who are trying
to take more and more and more power to
make more and more and more decisions
for themselves namely the bureaucrats
and the politicians and the ruling class
right you can't you can't sell natural
immunity and you can't
dispense natural immunity and it's it's
very hard to track natural immunity as
well so that the eggheads and the
bureaucrats and the power hungry people
want to pretend that it simply does not
exist and then real journalists go in
there and
get real answers
i know that we we use this term
journalist or reporter investigative
reporter very loosely these days the
people by and large who are working for
the corporate press
are not
investigative reporters
they're not going in and finding out the
truth and threatening power structures
they are the power structure
james o'keefe and project veritas and a
handful of other citizen journalists
those are people who are actually doing
that kind of job we talked about this a
little bit yesterday when you are
actually speaking truth to power the way
that you know that you are speaking
truth to power is that people don't like
you very much
okay you know there's this this
whistleblower quote unquote at facebook
and this whistleblower is she comes out
and then within i don't know 12 hours of
her coming out and becoming a
whistleblower she's got a twitter
account the twitter account is verified
she's got hearings scheduled on capitol
hill she's giving national tv
appearances she's being lauded
throughout the press this is not a
whistleblower this is a celebrity this
is a plant this is a pawn of the ruling
class okay a whistleblower is someone
who threatens the dominant power
structures and they're not going to be
given tv specials and blue check marks
you know within minutes of starting
their accounts and and lots of special
treatment and applause and standing
ovations they're not
not if they're actually threatening
power and the power
is clamping down up in america's hat our
neighbor to the north in canada justin
trudeau
had previously said that vaccine
mandates were a step too far and it
threatened people's religious and
medical liberty and they weren't going
to do that
you can hear what he used to say about
it and then listen to how he changed his
tune
what do you do with someone with an
allergy what do you do with someone uh
who's immunocompromised or someone who
for real religious or uh you know deep
conviction deep conviction deep
convictions uh decides that no they're
not going to get a vaccine we're not a
country that makes vaccination mandatory
for example that anyone wishing to
travel on a plane or a train
be vaccinated
and exemptions whether they're medical
exemptions or otherwise will be
exceedingly
narrow
specific
and to be honest somewhat onerous to
obtain
the goal is to make sure that everyone
who can chooses to get vaccinated but
let me say that
simply having a personal conviction that
vaccines are bad will not be
nearly enough to qualify for an
exemption to that simply having a
personal conviction that vaccines are
bad will not be
nearly enough so a lot of conservatives
are pointing to this and saying okay the
the first trudeau he was right and he
was saying the right thing and he was
good and then the second trudeau here
where he's talking about how he doesn't
care about people's personal convictions
that's really bad and so he used to have
a good stance now he's got a bad stance
i think it's more complicated than that
and i want to be as fair as i possibly
can to justin trudeau
i don't think the problem here is his
stance okay i think either of those
opinions that he just stated are
defensible as a national policy i think
when when he went out there and he said
look
this experimental drug and people you
know with people some people have
allergies some people have religious
objections and so we're not going to
push that perfectly reasonable i support
that policy then he comes out and he
says well look you can't just you can't
just have national policy based on
everyone's personal convictions because
then you can't have any national policy
at all so the threshold for a religious
exemption or something along those lines
has to be a little bit higher i think
he's right about that too
or even to go further and to say you
know this there's a principle in which
we can issue vaccine mandates frankly i
think even that is justifiable here in
the united states we've had at least in
principle a constitutional vaccine
mandates for well over 100 years george
washington for goodness sakes instituted
an inoculation mandate in the
continental army
so i don't i don't think we should go so
far on my individual liberty that we
that we
uh undermine ourselves or we make
incoherent arguments i don't think the
issue here is even trudeau's stance
i think it is
the lying the gaslighting the
flip-flopping the disingenuity
what what justin trudeau is doing here
is licking his finger putting it up in
the air and figuring out which way the
wind is blowing and trying to figure out
how much power he can take for himself
and now he he used to think he couldn't
take all that power now he thinks he can
take more power so he's going to take it
he's making contradictory arguments
and it shows you that our governments
our societies are rudderless we don't
really have a north star that's why we
keep contradicting ourselves all the
time and that's why people feel that our
our societies are unstable and that's
why our societies actually are unstable
and we can't we don't have faith in our
institutions anymore we don't have faith
in our traditions anymore and we don't
have faith in our own elections anymore
because we don't really seem to stand
for much of anything at all
yesterday
this seems disconnected but i actually
don't think it is yesterday on twitter
there was a trending headline you know
twitter has trending headlines on the
sidebar it said quote bill gates said
healthcare and vaccines could reduce
unstable unsustainable population growth
in a 2010 ted talk fact checkers say so
i looked at that i said wait a second
you're not you're not saying this is a
crazy kooky conspiracy that bill gates
said that vaccines
could could reduce the population and
population growth rather you're you're
saying that he actually did say this
according to
fact checkers and i looked it up and you
know reuters and the ap and they're all
trying to cover for bill gates a little
bit
saying always taken out of context or
whatever but then they've got the quote
and actually we've got the video clip
from the ted talk
and and bill gates says exactly that
somehow we have to make changes
that will bring that down to zero this
equation has four factors a little bit
of multiplication so you've got a thing
on the left co2 that you want to get to
zero
and that's going to be based on the
number of people
the services each person's using on
average
the energy on average for each service
and the co2 being put out
a per unit of energy so let's look at
each one of these
and see how we can get this down to zero
probably one of these numbers is going
to have to get pretty near to zero
now that's
back from high school algebra but let's
let's take a look
uh first we've got population
now the world today has 6.8 billion
people that's headed up to about 9
billion now if we do a really great job
on
new vaccines health care
reproductive health services we could
lower that by perhaps 10 or 15 percent
hold up hold up what
so you've got all these different
factors the people and the services
they're using and this and that so you
got to bring one of these numbers down
to zero you want to bring population
that doesn't sound good
okay and how are we going to reduce the
population well if we do a really good
job on health care by healthcare i think
he means abortion that's pretty clear
contraception or something at the very
least contraception and if we do a
really really good job on
reproductive services that's just
another dishonest euphemism to mean
abortion okay reproductive's okay if you
bring that and if we do a really good
job on vaccines then we can bring that
number down wait what i thought vaccines
are supposed to
improve health i thought vaccines were
supposed to allow more people to live
longer
so you're saying you do a good job on
vaccines and that's going to bring the
human population down or at least the
growth of the human population down
doesn't i and i'm not venturing a guess
as to what he meant here i i don't know
maybe he just misspoke maybe he didn't
misspeak
the one thing we do know about bill
gates though is that he has been
obsessed with reducing the number of
people who are born for decades now he's
given me i mean he's talking about it
here but he's given many many interviews
on this topic
it's been a weird hobby horse of the
anti-human left for decades well over a
century now
going back to the population bomb we
were told in in the 70s that the human
population was going to increase it was
going to lead to widespread famine we
had to
encourage people to have abortions and
to stop having children and to use
contraception and we might even need to
coerce people to do that
paul air like a scientist at stanford
said that and then what happened
between the time that book was published
and today the world population doubled
and what happened then malnutrition
dropped it's at an all-time low
people are fatter and better fed than
ever before the predictions were just
totally wrong but this is a weird
obsession
with just reducing the number of people
who exist
this is why we don't trust these people
bill gates is considered one of the at
least by the ruling class probably not
by most people but by the ruling class
he's considered one of the great
philanthropists of our age one of the
great geniuses because he sold a lot of
computers in the 90s you see and so
that's why he should opine about how the
world should be run bill gates this
great guy
the reason that we don't trust him he
became an expert somehow on vaccines
remember during covet he was like the
vaccine expert why i have the same
epidemiology degree that bill gates does
why was he the expert
why why don't i'll reverse the question
why don't people trust bill gates it's
not just because he doesn't have a
degree it's not just because he's
ignorant of on this topic
it's because
he and his ilk have a vision of the
world that is stupid and evil now i'm
not calling him evil he might just be
kind of stupid
smart computer salesman not the smartest
philosopher certainly not a great
theologian
doesn't understand all that much about
the human person
their vision of the world they're
putting out here
is a very stupid one first of all
because they keep
making these end of the world
apocalyptic predictions that don't come
true
but it's also an evil one
just as a rule of thumb if your vision
of the future of the world
hinges upon
stopping people from being born
either by killing babies through
abortion or by
you know pushing contraception
everywhere so that there are just fewer
people
you're you might be one of the baddies
okay you might be one of the not the
good guys one of the bad guys and
specifically bill gates is focused on
reducing population in africa and india
which adds a kind of racial component to
this you know yes there are enough of us
over here but what we need to do is
reduce the number of those those brown
people we've got too many brown people
they're breathing too much they've got
too much carbon dioxide so we've got to
stop that
if you are
crafting a vision of the world that
sacrifices human beings to nature gods
you might be one of the baddies you
might be doing exactly the same thing
that ancient pagans did to moloch and
baal and all the other sorts of demons
okay and you don't you're not aware of
it because you use all of these kind of
really sciency newfangled
jargony terms
but you're doing exactly the same thing
we've been going through in the past few
weeks we've been going through
lots of the stupid slogans and stupid
arguments that come up with that they
come up very often with abortion because
abortion is a big issue we've been
talking about 40 days for life we've
been talking about the supreme court the
supreme court case that's going to be
coming down to possibly reverse roe
versus wade we've been talking about the
pro-life law in texas new one coming up
now in florida
so i i keep going through all these
stupid slogans you know my body my
choice or
no uterus no opinion or whatever but
there is some guy
some
poor sap some schlubby millennial
feminist girly man who made a
an instagram video
of him singing a song about how great
abortion is and how it's wonderful to
have abortions
that to it takes all of the dumbest
arguments and slogans and just
just puts them all condenses them all
into one minute take a listen
some folks believe a life begins when
eggmates sperm and wanna force all
pregnant women to carry to term but
their actions point to something that
you wouldn't expect that they think kids
only matter when they're not born yet
they'll make your family and child care
funding fails take away their parents at
the border in jail kids beg for climate
action under crippling debt while you
show them they only matter when they're
not born yet
if abortion was the issue contraception
would reduce it oh
but wouldn't you know certain people
made it difficult for everyone to use it
wow
publicly shame them if they can't afford
lunch refuse to keep schools safe from
covet or guns for once i wish their
actions would disprove what i've said
that they think kids only matter when
they're not born yet
okay so this boils down to one slogan in
particular that you've heard
very ignorant leftists use for a long
time that republicans they're not
pro-life they're pro-birth
they're not for they only care about
kids when they're in the womb but then
they don't then they don't like kids or
something right
so
he wants me to just he says i wish they
would disprove my point so okay let's
disprove the points this is a short
video let's go through every single one
of them this is oh you posted of course
he posted it on tick tock all the
stupidest stuff in the world i've
noticed these days it's on tick tock
let's roll the tape
some folks believe a life begins when
eggmates spots
that is not just what some folks believe
that is what the science says
when when egg meets sperm that creates a
life it has all of the characteristics
of a life and it is not merely a part of
the father or of the mother as a sperm
or an egg cell might be but it creates a
new unique human being with a unique
genetic code that will
continue to grow that begins to grow and
that continues to grow into a human
being until his death it will continue
to grow in that same sort of process
with that same genetic code in that same
unique identity and life
until their death so it's not just what
some people believe that's what everyone
believes including a lot of uh
pro-abortion people by the way the
honest pro-abortion people the only
people who don't believe that are
ignorant or stupid or both continue
and want to force all pregnant women to
carry to terms
they want to force all pregnant women to
carry to term
that's one way to frame it
the other way to frame it is
some people believe that life begins at
conception namely
every person with eyes and ears and two
functioning brain cells and so we don't
think you should be able to kill that
person
for whatever reason just willy-nilly
that you should not be able to kill
innocent babies correct move on
their actions point to something that
you wouldn't expect that they think kids
only matter when they're not born yet
so
this is his thesis
we've established i think the kids
matter
when they're
in the womb
he seems to be implying that the left
doesn't believe kids matter when they're
in the womb and his thesis is they only
met they don't matter at all afterwards
okay why not
they'll make your family leave and child
care funding fails take away their
parents at the border
so first of all a lot of a lot of
republicans and conservatives support
family leave sorts of policies don't
forget the trump administration was
pushing one even if you don't support
family leave policies one of the reasons
that people don't support that is they
don't want the government and the state
to grow to take over the raising of
children because we believe that the
family should take care of children so
we certainly support an economy that
allows a mother to stay home with her
child for instance we certainly support
an economic policy that encourages
people to have families
we certainly support local communities
helping to raise up kids we certainly
support even even the most mainstream
you know
chamber of commerce republican supports
child tax care credits for instance but
i i also think it's just an outdated
talking point because so many
conservatives these days are pushing for
explicitly pro-family policies look at
what victor orban is doing in hungary
look how which is encouraging the growth
of families and look at how many
conservatives support those kind of
policies here we've now become sort of
hungary-philic over here in the the
united states because we want that kind
of policy so it's also just dated kind
of rhetoric keep going it's begged for
climate action under crippling death
while you show them they only matter
when they're not born yet
pause so he says you're gonna put your
you're gonna throw the parents in jail
and separate them from the kids first of
all that's not a republican policy that
policy began under bill clinton it
continued under barack obama the left
only cared about it under donald trump
and now it's continuing to happen under
joe biden but but even beyond that what
we're saying is don't come here yes stay
with your family stay with your family
and your country because we don't want
to separate anybody and we don't we we
can't just have open borders continue
contraception
that's not true that isn't true so there
is no evidence that contraception
actually reduces abortion obviously
since the growth of contraception you've
seen an increase in the abortion rate
during the 20th century nearly all these
are according to a number of studies
99.1 percent of sexually experienced
women in the u.s have used contraception
at some point so everyone has access to
conception and basically everyone uses
it at some point 48 of women with
unintended pregnancies were using
contraception in the month they
conceived about half of pregnancies
ended by abortion occur during the use
of contraceptives 10 of women using
reversible forms of contraception become
pregnant over 12 months of use and among
women at risk of unintended pregnancy 89
use contraception so that talking point
just complete complete bs even though
even though cod reception is available
to everyone complete bs keep going
but wouldn't you know certain people
made it difficult for everyone to use it
wow
publicly shame them if they can't afford
lunch refuse to keep schools safe from
cove or guns
kids aren't at risk from covid in any
particular way i'm not saying they have
a zero percent risk but they have a very
very very low risk from coronavirus all
of the science agrees with that in terms
of uh guns uh we went through the
numbers the other day but people are at
a far greater risk of dying from knives
and from clubs and from hammers and bats
than they are from ar-15s or really guns
of any sort other than
if you're talking about democrat-run
cities with gang violence with pistols
with all sorts of illegal uh weapons but
again you can't you can't really blame
conservatives for that can you keep
going once i wish their actions would
disprove what i've said that they think
it's only matter when they're not born
yet
not only have we disproved what you said
with our facts and logic but also i
think with our actions we have
conservatives are much more likely to
donate to charity conservatives
obviously are pushing a lot of crisis
pregnancy centers and conservatives are
are very likely to
support adoption and there are 36
couples willing to adopt every new baby
in america who's put up for adoption
complete b-s it just shows you that big
difference between the appearance what
we're told from the left the narratives
that we're told by the ruling class
and the reality of the situation and
when people wake up to it
it is almost shocking to see the lies
that we're all living in i'm michael
knowless the michael knowles show see
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell agrees
to a temporary debt ceiling increase
president biden's approval rating
craters and espn suspends at sage steele
for saying in the unsavable that's today
on the bench spiroshall give it a listen